[Music]
you've probably heard this conversation
starter many times before
tell me about yourself you might answer
with your name where you're from and
maybe a fun fact whether you've thought
about these details deeply or not they
lay the foundation of a story that
reflects you
the building of this story plays a
critical role in narrative medicine
narrative medicine is the practice of
mindfully contextualizing a patient's
lived experiences to better care for and
treat them
it's an approach to healthcare that
considers not only the physical but also
the mental and emotional aspects of a
person's health
by seeking out a patient's story
clinicians can gain an in-depth
perspective of their patient and
ultimately see a whole person not just a
diagnosis
narrative medicine requires a vast array
of skills clinicians must be able to
listen to comprehend and act upon a
patient's story
sometimes a patient's story isn't clear
cut so clinicians also need to be able
to navigate its nuances this set of
skills is called narrative competence
and clinicians can improve their
narrative competence through creative
expression
narrative medicine provides a solution
to common challenges faced by clinicians
and patients
a clinician cannot rely on their medical
knowledge alone to prevent diagnose and
treat illnesses if they cannot
communicate and connect with their
patient the patient may feel neglected
invalidated or even hesitant to return
for another visit in some cases a
clinician may miss the correct diagnosis
or the prescribed treatment may be
ineffective if a patient is from a
marginalized population that has
suffered historical racial or other
categorical trauma the disconnect can be
even larger
the most common sources of disconnect
between a clinician and a patient are
known as the four divides these are
obstacles that hamper the development of
a strong patient clinician connection
the first divide is differing views on
mortality
while clinicians primarily encounter
illness and death through their work
patients often react more strongly based
on their personal experiences
the second divide is the context of
illness
most clinicians see illness as a
phenomenon requiring medical
intervention while a patient may see
illness as the effect it has on their
life and on others
the third divide is differing beliefs
about the causes of disease
not only do clinicians have extensive
medical training but their knowledge is
also valued more than their patients
creating an unequal balance
the final divide is vulnerability
patients may be hesitant to share
personal details about their lives and a
clinician may be hesitant to inquire
making the process of diagnosis and
treatment more difficult and stressful
through conversations narrative medicine
can result in more personalized care
with improved health outcomes
researchers at the university of new
england found that veterans who were
asked to share their personal stories
experienced less chronic pain than those
who were not
additionally clinicians who listened to
the stories of veterans experienced less
emotional burnout
while there were many accounts of the
healing benefits of narrative medicine
there are constraints to the approach
first there is a limited amount of
empirical evidence on the effectiveness
of narrative medicine the training
needed to practice it and how it relates
to disease and illness outcomes
narrative medicine also takes time and
how to manage that time efficiently is a
concern for incorporating it into modern
medical practices
additionally narrative medicine is a
tool not a cure clinicians need to
understand that using narrative medicine
does not guarantee a smooth patient
provider relationship
finally narrative medicine cannot fully
capture someone's entire story
this stance is known as narrative
humility
although the field of narrative medicine
is relatively new the use of stories
within patient clinician care is not
in fact storytelling has a long history
in medical practices outside of western
medicine
negoma is just one example of this
by combining stories with rhythms and
dance the ceremony has been a source of
traditional healing in central and
southern africa for countless
generations
narrative medicine continues to be
introduced on both national and global
scales initiatives that utilize the
approach have sprouted in the united
states england france taiwan and
pakistan
medical schools and other healthcare
institutions have incorporated narrative
medicine courses and workshops into
their curriculum and community education
and narrative medicine is gradually
becoming part of the western medical
norm
narrative medicine helps bridge the gap
of misunderstanding between clinicians
and patients and by doing so connects
individuals with themselves others and
the diverse landscapes in which they all
live
everyone has a unique story and
narrative medicine seeks to honor these
stories to build a healthier and more
connected world
[Music]
[Music]
you